okay guys so I'll be talking about an
interesting modification of classical
condenser protocols so what I really
want to show you guys at the end of this
talk is a protocol that is in the normal
case operation effectively optimal and
it's basically o of one message
complexity logarithmic number of steps
in Layton sees but in implementation
I'll show you a real-life implantation
of it it's still performing in sub
second finality across the network of
two thousand plus nodes and it can go
ten thousand hundred thousand without
really much of a hitch so this work by
the way while you know it's from from
our labs and Cornell it has has some
roots in work of Jared SIA and Valerie
King they started introducing these
ideas earlier on but they never really
caught on even though they are really
really powerful so consensus until now
we have two major families
it's Nakamoto style and voting based
protocols I don't need to tell you guys
exactly how this work but classical has
a really nice property its final as soon
as you reach quorum you're basically
done you don't need to wait for you know
any other craziness you can make it a
synchronous so as soon as you get a
quorum you finalize you get the
certificate and you're done they have
super high performance because of that
so the second and you reach your you're
required to quorum
you can basically give a certificate to
the client and that can run into the sub
second Layton sees unfortunately because
you do need to query everybody I need to
grab everybody's votes there happens to
be clearly a bottleneck here whether you
move that to the leader or not if you do
move that's a leader that leader will be
bottom like entirely by the ability to
accumulate votes and then show votes to
everybody else in the network
Nakamoto introduced something
fundamentally revolutionary which is
that it said screw voting let's just
throw identities out the window we're
just gonna now basically reach consensus
on whatever this longest chain heaviest
chain thing is as long as you show me
something that looks heavier than
anything else in the world then I'm
gonna
assume that is a canonical chain and I'm
gonna go with it that's great because it
now is effectively independent of the
number of nodes because you don't even
need identities anymore you just need to
broadcast blocks and hear what the
longest chain is unfortunately because
you have a bounded synchronicity
assumption and there is a bounded size
to every block there is in fact a
bounded amount of messages and therefore
usually very low amount of transactions
that can be fit into this especially if
you want to you know sustain like
clients and you can't just simply
increase the block size or you know make
the confirmation times shorter simply
because then you're gonna preclude a
whole lot of machines from the network
from ever participating you're gonna
make the network centralize towards
really powerful machines and there's a
lot of debates and obviously the space
is very divided on on you know how block
sizes should be and there's Bitcoin cash
in Bitcoin and there's been a lot of
Forks in regards to this so there's been
a lot of work in the past few years
trying to improve on these pitfalls
we've seen in Nakamoto in all
suggestions make blocks bigger introduce
some form of shard ink layer to like
lightning networks has been very popular
and it's catching on to some degree
although it has it's a set of problems
there's notions of pre consensus to
reduce latency so you use effectively a
voting based mechanism to finalize
blocks or rather get a snapshot of what
the current blocks are and then finalize
them through proof work and then layer 0
get really really good at distributing
blocks around the the network and
there's been a bunch of companies that
have a spin a spun off doing exactly
that on the classical end I don't need
to tell you guys there's been decades
and decades of really fantastic work
trying to optimize protocols in all
sorts of ways oftentimes they end up
optimizing for worst case scenarios and
worst case scenarios as even in you know
nowadays in blockchains
if catastrophic events in a really bad
scene has happened they tend to not
really matter because we end up doing
social consensus anyway and it's it's
you know it's a little bit disappointing
because there's they're supposed to be
unstoppable decentralized system
but ultimately there is really a whole
lot of parties that that can have a lot
of say here outside of the protocol but
in classical we've seen all kinds of
optimizations to optimize that lowest of
that worst case low you know round
number optimizations we've used
cryptographic tricks we've used
aggregation signatures and so on to
reduce the the message complexity
sharding is of course another one and
improving on the leader election the
question is can we sort of make
something really simple that doesn't
require any kind of craziness but still
can get to this almost magical of one
message complexity effectively a network
that performs you know the same
regardless of whether you have 10,000
nodes or 1 million nodes so we've kind
of really need to rethink it and I'm
gonna propose the following so in
classical voting protocols you sample
everybody else you grab what their
status you create a certificate you can
create an aggregation a certificate
reduce it move it on to the next round
so you can reduce the message complexity
for that round but ultimately you're
aggregating what everybody is saying and
showing it to everybody else that there
has been some certificate and has been
some consensus reached amongst everybody
instead what if we don't do that what if
we effectively do the following let's
suppose that we're all in this room and
instead of and we're trying to decide
whether we're trying to go to Chipotle
or Mo's is Mo's on this coast no it's a
it's a Chipotle like alternative and
they both serve burritos and we're
trying to decide which one of these to
go and some people like Chipotle some
people like Mo's but we all just wanna
go to the same place so everybody in
this room instead of me saying hey guys
we're gonna go to Chipotle or I'm gonna
go to Moe's
instead everybody samples their local
set of people and ask hey what do you
want to be and gets that majority and
you repeat this locally over a few
rounds
turns out this is sufficient and I'll
get to the kinds of message complexities
achieves but it's sufficient to achieve
really high security distributed
consensus effectively independent of the
network size it's this has been known
for a lot of time in
in voter based models in sarcastic
processing you know voter protocols can
scale independently of the network size
by just sampling local but but really
just doing local observations because
local observations tend to be as like
tend to estimate global state pretty
accurately especially if you keep
repeating it yes the latency to
confirmation will be log in and the
message complexity and I'll show you why
it'll be oh of one because we amortize
it in the in a real implementation
binary consensus in fact it will be
message complexity and latency will be
log in
all of one per node in the amortized
setting but I haven't gotten there yet
so the basic mechanism is super simple
we have a bunch of nodes they are red or
blue they're trying to zero one the Tron
design on binary consensus every node
samples a random subset of other nodes
gets their value in this case the red
node samples a majority blue hard way
this note here samples the majority blue
and then it becomes blue itself and yes
sounds like you and files but talk
essentially it's saying let's take any
probabilistic or stochastic process it
is an avalanche yes
turns out it's a pretty powerful
technique so well we'll build it
aggressively so the up and every node
here has no notion of rounds it does not
care it just samples keeps going you
know it doesn't really care no
synchronization nothing it just keeps
going and every node does sampling
independent of other nodes turns out and
I'm not so I adapted this talk from a
talk that I gave it Potsie co-located
with Part C and I want to keep you just
high level not going to the mathematics
of it but the math shows that
effectively if you just do this random
sampling and then you go to whatever the
some threshold majority of nodes are
saying in your local neighborhood then
as soon as you get to a point where
the majority of the network in this case
like out of a thousand nodes the
majority like you know 80 plus percent
are a particular color it becomes really
unlikely for the other you know color
the minority color to ever win out again
so if most of us have you know decided
that we're going to Chipotle but some
people are still at most it's very
unlikely that most people will ever win
out in fact it's very very likely you
know one minus Epsilon so the let's make
sure that I state this from the very
beginning so there's no confusion there
is no rent global randomness everybody
just samples locally good and the second
thing what the you're asking what the
adversary can do in our model the
adversary can do anything it wants it
can check well not every it can only not
change the state of correct nodes so it
is bounded by some percentage it can
view the state of every other node
infinitely quickly and it can change its
own values infinitely quickly the
message delays yes
in our model yes and it will it will
shutdown liveness in that case but if
you assume that it doesn't control the
network message delays this network this
system will make progress but it will
still be safe even if it controls the
message device so liveness synchronicity
safety doesn't matter it's good one
across it okay so you may have heard of
me trolling people online about
avalanche and this is what we're on
twitter this is what we were building so
avalanche is effectively one of the
implementations of this family of kiss
pro cause it's probabilistic
because it's proposed it builds a dag
and i will show you a linear version of
this very soon but it builds a dag
because payments if you want to build a
cryptocurrency
our commutative you don't really need to
order them in a linear order and I'm not
going to go through the because this
happens to be like a secondary talked
almost on how to build dag based
payments and it gets really complicated
but effectively you know you can you
know if this means alla space Charlie as
a transaction and then I introduce
another transaction that says Charlie
pays Fiona if I sample this transaction
and people say this transaction looks
good then it automatically means that
this one is good and this one is good as
well so every single transaction is
queried only once never again you move
on to the next transaction that comes
after it now let's skip this so in a
real implementation this is two thousand
nodes up to two thousand nodes this is
actual real C++ permutation geo
distributed on AWS with latency
simulated nodus retinal performance
changes across the number of nodes it
doesn't really matter if he's to 120 125
all the way to 2000 it performs the same
and that we haven't gone to ten thousand
and so on but I think this sort of shows
roughly how this performs sub-second
latencies which is which is pretty nice
so about zero point to 200 milliseconds
on average and maximum about like one to
two seconds on the tail
okay so avalanche achieves a partial
ordering which is good for commutative
operations like payments but if you want
to achieve a total or drink let's do it
so pretty simple actually
it's effectively avalanche but the dag
builds you know every node has one child
and in one parent every node samples if
this is a fork in the system and each
one of these blocks happen let's be one
transaction per block every node samples
it only wants initially there is a low
threshold for choosing the fork let's
say I just simple choose choose a simple
majority whichever is a simple majority
so I can tie break that's at some point
if I achieve some sort of a depth here
I'm going to call this depth DL then I
move to a higher threshold majority and
if I get a high threshold majority for
some number of data consecutive rounds
I am statistically guaranteed that we
have all moved to this chain right here
as long as you know
violate the number of Byzantine nose
being above some threshold and I can
choose this this uh this valley to
whatever if I choose it to be you know
roughly two-thirds then I can you know
tolerate up to one-third for liveness in
Byzantine ODEs and if I make it really
high for six for safety guarantees then
I obviously can tolerate less in
liveness so a Byzantine average so you
can just choose never to reply and we
don't make we don't make any progress
but I think safety over aliveness here
is is quite important
yeah so she's that and it becomes at
some point this becomes the finalized
state so so it's interesting we get
about oh of one message complexity and I
think it's an interesting set of family
of Critias protocols they are safe under
a synchrony the adversary can choose
whatever message devices it wants live
only under synchrony of course and
effectively they just give you a you
know the claim is here in the in the
normal case operation they give you
optimal message complexity and I want to
show you as well I'm here to plug and I
want to show you a real this is actually
the entire ethereal virtual machine
running on snowman it is live
we're only blasting it little by little
but it is live it's working and it's
running on i-25 no implementation which
is low but that's because we don't want
to overpay on AWS so we can pass it two
thousand and so on and it'll be good so
is it thank you we have some time for
questions
something is local right yes something
notes can also come and a lot of them
can actually your I mean because
building nodes say one third is there
but those can actually follow those
sensor a lot actually and they keep you
okay for one set of node they can say
you don't you don't care when do you
come to know that EQ question I mean
it's not going to affect how do you
realize
you don't care about the technical
vacation that's the nice thing about
this we can build more sophisticated
versions of this a detected but you
don't care you basically the following
statement guarantees that you are safe
if you achieve high threshold majority
for some beta consecutive around so I
see much like eighty percent blue for
twenty times in a row I know for a fact
there is no chance as long as the number
of Byzantines hasn't been you know it's
not above the assumption that we have
set up then there is no way for the
other color to everywhere now so you
don't care about detecting the
convocations here for the experiment
that we ran we ran a sample size so the
security guarantee that we put up for
that experiment was a failure once every
20,000 years running with the network
running assuming at 10,000 per second
per second that was the failure rate
that we chose and the sample size I
think was about twenty nodes per round
and the threshold majority was like
about eighty percent it's log it was
like like less than seventeen for sure
yeah but it's if you amortize it in the
in the blockchain then it's the aperture
you can control the network you can make
sure that only the red guys can talk to
each other and only the blue guys
have to do this for as long as you want
yep will not each decide because no they
just need to because the the repeated
samplings will fail they oh because they
will sample the adversary shuts it down
it doesn't get the consecutive they have
view of the network they're sampling
randomly from the entire view of the
network sure it can
but even if it's completely splits in
half and I keep sampling I see that like
I'm not getting threshold majority from
from because this entire half of the
stadium is shut down if you said it
let's say 80% I say that if there's no
aggregate means something specific I
sample let's say ten of ten people in
this room and if I see eight of them say
the same thing then I consider that to
be successful like it's a successful
round yes yes you know the number
correct you choose the format head of
time the adversary does not get to
choose the forums yes okay which remain
exhibition which is how far are you from
the background change from developing
what we have so I mean the quorum change
which chord change but let's let's let's
be clear here the the quorum change for
the yeah I'm not sure what there's
there's no quorum here it's only local
there's no canonical quorum
so no you you uniformly sample from the
set of participants you mean how do new
participants come into the system ah for
a staking based protocol they come in
they say I would like to become a
validator so they submit a staking
transaction they lock up some number of
coins and then they can participate in
the system yes yes this is fully
implemented currently in testing mode I
see what you were asking for yes safe
yes safe under a asynchronous network
the number in normal case scenario which
means that you know the adversary is not
if the adversary is less than the
assumptions that you assumed and and so
on then you get logarithmic number of
steps to to confirmation and all of one
advertised message complexity you can
parameterize it so currently we so we we
permit we parameterize for high safety
and lower liveness we set the threshold
to about 80% which means that it's about
20% for liveness so if more than 20% of
nodes are Byzantine you shut down
liveness it's the mixing time of the
mark option amortize because for every
so if you had a binary codes results
there's no adversary' the communication
browsers
yes for every round in a classical
protocol you can advertise like for
example hot stuff does you get ofn
because at every round you do a sampling
of the entire network for us we do a
constant size sampling that sample that
we choose it's actually independent of
the network size so it's o of one per
round
but isn't a search to a majority
diversity majority converges to a
majority and login and log in number of
rounds but per round I only have message
complexity constant size
so here's a tip consensus unit Logan
steps
correct Logan steps the whole network
yes to achieve there's no more ties
absolutely correct it's in the time
exactly right exactly right yes yes it's
possible this is very unlikely if you
split the network in half and I keep
sampling and I'm unable to reach half
the network every one of my samples will
fail
I can't I'm out just to make progress
but I will not reach this beta
consecutive you know super majority
threshold it'll be very unlikely eighty
percent the quorum is local it's it's
yeah you choose it locally for every
round is choose a random set of quorum
notes for if you want liveness it's
synchronous protocol this has to be
synchronized yeah correct correct if I
speak in login grounds
so how do I know that the result that
I'm getting this is correct because oh
you don't set out I see you don't set so
the what the protocol says is that if
you get beta a number of rounds
consecutive supermajority then you know
that that decision has been finalized it
doesn't say that it's necessarily the
case for example if the visit the
adversary controls the network and
splits it in half it will happen in
logarithmic number of rounds if the
network adversary splits in their can
half it'll take exponentially many
rounds for it to to finalize
yes if I want the same tolerance for
lightning and lightness and safety yes
it's one one third yes that's where they
meet as I told a club that's all voting
based protocols that are safe under a
synchrony
if you start introducing before scene
you have you yes yes so if you have a
leaderless version so there's no node
that creates any univalent see like the
network can be split in half every
single time then there is a well-known
upper bound of square root and number of
Byzantine nodes to stall logarithmic
number of rounds progress lightness so
it would take more than logarithm the
number of rounds if the business in
adversary is more than square root n if
you introduce a leader and the leader
just really means a soft ticketing
service like you send in a transaction
and then it sends it to a few other
nodes and those will do then the
propagation then that leader it becomes
effectively the same as though you know
booting other classical based protocols
so you can get it to one third roughly
one third minus some errors because it's
a there's some probability there failure
it's like effectively classical voting
based protocols except that I don't use
the entire quorum of the network
I still get those guarantees of you know
supermajority but every single sample
that I get unlike in classical where I
know for sure that is probability one
that my view my local view is is to be
is the same as the global view because
by definition my local view is the is
the global view in our version the local
view is not has some error from the
global view so I repeat the local view a
few times to get a very high estimate of
the global view that's really all it's
it's doing in the background and then it
turns out that each one of these rounds
can be amortized so you can get really
nice performance here that is happening
through SEM so whenever I sample
somebody and I say first time I hear
about red I asked other people hey what
do you prefer red or blue they don't
care exactly so they give you empty
answer they say we don't have this so
that was a failure on your end so okay I
repeat it now each one of those guys
when they first hear about red they say
oh okay let me ask what other people
think about right now I know about red
it was my first value that I saw it's
the one that I prefer I guess because
it's the first one so now I'm gonna
sample other people somebody else sees
blue for the first time they go to blue
and they start sampling other people
say I have no idea
yes
and one person says yes if the majority
of I will accept anything any individual
says but I will only move to the
majority color I will only change my
mind if I'm correct no you will take the
majority per protocol correct yes if
you're Byzantine you can choose to say
red blue constantly you can do it you
can do whatever you want you can you can
say anything you want so great question
so in the leaderless case yeah so the
leaderless case each Fork is defined via
patricia tree so you have I mean each
block is defined as a hash you are
making progress on the first bit of the
hash that's the binary decision so each
fork will have either a 0 or 1 as the
next decision and if the fork if you
want to really make it such that you
have 256 decisions then you would have
to create a fork that is exponentially
large basically would mean that at every
at every bit you would have to create to
two forks as an attack corruptor value
by this corrupting one-way trade
corruptive value would the way I'm sure
it is you're doing this goodbye playboy
the hash values yes yes and you're going
for either red or blue and the the
guarantees that you have at the end of
factors you will have one of the two
values you don't know which yes so if I
have let's say a third stake I can and
let's say although I just want to commit
to one I can come up with a zero value
zero value just for one vector and then
the entire hash is corrupted right
because if everything is okay except for
one bit
I mean you check the validity of the
block the hash first and now we started
so if I see that I have two blocks if I
have these two and these both look like
valid Forks this one starts off with a
bit of zero this one starts off with a
bit of one I'll decide on that side
first okay I decided the first bit is
zero which is this one so I just discard
this one
all right when you used to not be
visited in mind
absolutely absolutely yeah I'm doing a
lightness attack here yeah so I think I
think I'm done with with the talk so
please
[Applause]